it's been the burning question will
president Trump attend the White House
Correspondents Dinner at the end of the
month now as you know he didn't go last
year because of his feud with the press
and now Don we have an answer why did
the gridiron dinner a few weeks ago and
that was really terrific we had a lot of
fun and it was good but I sort of feel
that the press is so bad it's so fake
yeah it's so made-up I mean sources say
and they have no sources they're like
novelists I call them novelists they
make up the sources now in some cases
their sources but then they won't do it
correctly either but in many cases they
literally make up sources you know nine
sources within the White House have said
there are no nine sources so I just
think that I want to get it straightened
out with the press before I do it so
it's probably pretty unlikely I won't -
well the White House said today press
secretary Sarah Sanders will go in mr.
Trump's face now did the president make
the right move considering how the press
treats them here are just a few of the
latest examples Alex
instead of Trump makes bizarre false
claims can you say Trump lies and then
just put in parentheses again close
parentheses about illegal voting
he's as dismissive of truth as he is of
ethics it is a device that works up to a
point and I'm sad to say that it also
can lead to the the diminishment of
democracy if not its death fear is the
lubricant of trumpism small petty cruel
mean-spirited fear and that's what we
saw today
fear is the lubricant of dictators we
know he likes dictators a whole lot I
mean just a few you could put a whole
hour of this and we would just never
even get enough of it right I mean come
on and then there's what do you think of
this good decision bad is the lubricant
is just stuck in my brain I think I
think it's a good decision I'm sure most
of us have been to these dinners I've
been to two or three it is
fake its fake er than the scenery and
sound of music and I you know it may
they would say well it's a good cause
and you should go but it's really
pathetic it's a pathetic event there are
two groups right there are there's the
press and there are the celebrities that
the press invites okay and the
celebrities wander around the auditorium
like cool kids at an ugly farm which it
is and the press indulges the
celebrities while climbing over each
other for selfies it's really
embarrassing and sad to see like grown
men and women acting really stupid
because oh my god that person is in that
sitcom the other thing is which I love
about this this on a personal note is
that the dinner is Saturday night and if
Donald Trump isn't going then I'm hoping
my show the Greg Gutfeld show Saturday
10:00 is not covering it live because it
is the most tedious waste of time I
could imagine we could counter-program
do something more fun maybe have Donald
Trump on right yeah I agree with you a
hundred percent there's absolutely no
reason the president should go to this
at all sycophants serving sycophants
they hate him so much yet they want him
so much yeah it's there like they run
against him every single day that what
they want to bask in his glow so that
they can mock him look at who they're
giving awards to so Trevor Noah is
hosting it CNN is getting an award for
fantastic journalism NBC is getting an
award for fantastic journalism and the
New York Times faked the failing New
York Times Maggie Haberman getting award
for fantastic trevor is I think it's a
right I think it's a writer from The
Daily Show Michelle wolf correspondent
from the show I'm sure equally fair
equally fair and entertaining and so the
embodiment of everything president Trump
campaign yes it's the media elites this
is the swamp and so I love the
juxtaposition of what he did last year
during the night of the dinner when he
handled that rally in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania and I hope he does the same
thing goes to Wisconsin goes to Ohio and
stands there as he did last year looking
at those people and saying you're the
Forgotten men and woman I am with you
well all of those people that we hate
that I'm campaigning against part of the
swamp they're all back in DC you know
mucking it up right and so I think it's
really smart and I think you should go
hit the campaign trail and do the exact
same thing he did last year that's so
interesting because you wonder one what
else could he do that would delight you
and enthrall you honestly be so bored
really what would we do because and what
we would do for ratings he's just the
ratings oh we got Hillary what we have
Hillary Hillary that's right you have
that's a good point but I must say you
guys seem to you guys seem to take a
one-sided view this I think it was
Donald Trump who said the press is the
enemy of the American people and I think
Steve banning calls from the opposition
nobody Trump said fake news but then it
seems to me like you know some of these
bites that we played at the top of the
show people are complaining about
something very legitimate which is that
he said oh these immigrant women are
getting raped right they don't that
there were so many illegal votes
you know fraudulent votes in California
that is swung I mean like what is going
on he has no evidence for this then the
press points it out and you guys say
there goes the press again but it's not
just Donald Trump it's also CBS's John
Dickerson said the media's done a good
enough job of ruining the reputation on
their own they're the ones who
illegitimate themselves you look at all
these stories that have been so
egregiously wrong whether it's the ABC
Brian Ross story whether it's stories
with cn and just getting blatant simple
facts like a timeline incorrect so
they're the ones that have damaged their
own reputation so don't you think that
the media bears some root culpability
here sure we always people make mistakes
we make mistakes every but I mean that
that's true of every presidency to my
mind and I must say I think I've been
the almost you know every one of them
since 1980 and the only one time the
president missed was Ronald Reagan after
he was shot mm-hmm I mean so there's a
reason I mean you put it down as like
psycho fancy or whatever you said but
you know in reality it's an opportunity
for people who often are in direct
conflict and you know the kind of press
versus powerful people to second say
slow down that's why guess who went to
the gridiron dinner just a few weeks ago
that was even more exclusive elite it
was Donald Trump
now that wasn't televised this is
televised this is more open actually
this is far more democratic than the
gridiron dinner I think well Oh
all I know is I can go by my own
experience being there and it is a
sweaty sweaty pathetic huddle of wannabe
celebrities up against celebrities and
it and the idea of sitting at home
watching a dinner when you could be
watching something real like the Greg
Gutfeld show or jesse's show or judge
Jeanine interesting I'm trying to plug
it's Saturday night everybody's a key
and there's Fox and Friends one day yes
it's a huddle of self-important people
that believe they're saving the republic
from Donald Trump when if you watch the
way this dinner went through eight years
of Barack Obama he may have attended it
but he was attending a chorus of
clapping seals who were who were
propagating his his administration for
eight years so to think that Donald
Trump's get anywhere near a fair hearing
and not just be smeared I think it's
fantasy talking and he is I think he's a
see something say something president
you talk about all the different aspects
of is it technically every aspect he
identifies thing like lawlessness on our
southern border and says we can't have
it we got to do something about it and
the press picks it apart no matter what
yeah but you bring up a great point
because if you look at this from like a
larger scale get some elevation on it
they're they're very unfair to the
president the press is they will not
give the credit for the absolute facts
of what he's done in terms of his
accomplishments as national security and
the economy what he's trying to do with
immigration how he's deregulated and got
rid of some of the problems that are the
siphoning the economy back they don't
want to admit any of it they don't want
to give him credit for any of the things
that he's done so that's what his cause
of this relationship to be the way it
every you mean Ann Coulter
oh because I think I think Ann Coulter
is not before the press
I think she's attacking him from the
right and I think that when people say
hey you didn't deliver on the wall or
you mr. president our Republican don't
we believe in free trade and we see the
stock market exercising volatility say
hey mr. president why are you starting
Oh
says Larry Kudlow we're not having a
trade war the next morning more
penalties on China and more trade war
and more before happening yet there's an
evening of the scales actually nothing
has happened do what they're just
talking about it can we just say that
what the obvious thing is here he's not
going because he's smart you don't go to
a place where people are just gonna
insult you for two hours or three hours
just to say but now your point earlier
was what I was thinking they would kiss
his butt really really because he's the
president you think it would always look
they always honor the office the
president and that's why you say they
want him to come because getting an
award at this dinner for a broadcast in
the broadcast category for their
coverage of Russia right
have you watched CNN in their coverage
of Russia it's the most one-sided
slanted assault on this president they
get the award for manufacturing fake
news this morning said you know we've
got to see the larger thing he
encourages people in other countries to
go after their press this is not good
for Dumanis all right there you go